most of the defendants will be 25 or
under and once I say that you will see
immediately what's been happening in our
society somewhere along the line an
awful lot of people are going to walk
out of prison who have spent decades
perhaps as long as they had lived out in
the community in prison if we think they
are going to walk out and fit seamlessly
back into society where living in a
Cloud Cuckoo Land but you want to know
um if I'm the man of the street and I
believe that the purpose of the criminal
justice system is to administer
punishment and we as a society do seem
to agree with that we punish people for
committing serious Crimes by putting
them in prison what is the point of that
why do we do
that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kiss and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today I'm
pleased to say he's a recently retired
Old Bailey judge and the author of a
recent book called unlawful killings
Wendy Joseph Casey welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me oh
it's such a pleasure to you on the show
I I swallowed your book basically in an
evening it was that good um and we'll
talk more about everything to do with
that but before we do tell everybody
watching and listening who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that lead you to be
sitting here talking to us uh well it's
quite a long journey that's quite a big
question um I um started off as an
ordinary school kid down in Cardiff
which is in Wales capital of Wales um I
wanted to be a writer it's what I wanted
to do uh I went off to University to
read English halfway through my mom said
to me how exactly do you reckon you're
going to make a living uh out of that um
so we thought it through together and I
changed to law and so I went to the bar
and um did that for 32 years 10 of which
as a QC Queen's Council uh cuz we had a
queen then uh then I decided for various
reasons I just didn't want to do that
anymore and applied to sit as a judge I
sat as an ordinary Crown Court Judge
dealing with jury trials for 4 and a
half years and then was moved to the Old
Bailey uh where I was for the next 10
years and now you have become a writer
as as you'd hope and at the age of 70 I
came right back full circle to where I
was when I first decided I was going to
be a writer at the age of seven and
what's fascinating is uh High judges
generally particularly people at Old
Bailey which is the central criminal
core I should explain for people in this
country which tries the most serious
cases mostly murder uh and and some
others um don't tend to write books well
in fact they they don't write books and
you only retired about a year and a bit
ago and you've written this book so it's
a fascinating look at how decisions are
made and the sort of crimes that are
being committed and the sort of crimes
that people deal with um one of the most
interesting uh things uh in the book is
you're obviously dealing with an issue
that's highly topical at the moment
which is knife crime uh and you wrestle
with you know the the crimes but also
how we've ended up in the position that
we've ended up now with your experience
you mentioned your 70 and you you did
that for a long time how has the
landscape of crime changed in this
country the sorts of cases you would see
before you uh have we always had as much
knife crime as we seem to have now has
that grown in recent years what is the
situation uh I don't know the statistics
but I do know my experience so I would
have begun uh going to the Old Bailey uh
as a barrister when I first came to the
bar as a baby Barrister if I was lucky
enough to be briefed as Junior Council
sitting behind ACCC in a big case um and
if you walked along the corridors of the
Old Bailey where there are 18 courts you
would have seen a few murders quite a
few murders but that have been caught
after court with armed robberies with
rapes with cases uh of a nonfatal
nature you don't see that so much at the
Old Bailey anymore
frankly you barely see it at all nearly
every courtroom for years now would have
been occupied with murders um or bit of
terrorism there are other things but
essentially that's what goes on there um
not necessarily murders let me replace
that with the word homicides because
there are different ways of killing
people but that's what we do and even
the lowest level homicide
even and I don't want to downplay the
gravity of them but even something as
um how do I put it without making it
sound as if it is less serious even
something like death by careless driving
you've got a death there uh that's what
we do there but most of the courtrooms
will be dealing with death using weapons
and most of the weapons will be knives
and most of the defendants will be 25 or
under and once I say that you will see
immediately what's been happening in our
society the rise of gangs the links
between gangs and drugs gangs and
violence intergang violence so so um
there has been to my mind and in my
experience a sea change now I know that
people will produce statistics that um
throw different angles on that but I
think it is clear there has been a
change over the last 45 years since I
became a barister and when did you start
noticing this change Wendy when when did
the change start occurring for
you w
um I have certainly seen it since I I've
been a judge in 2007 but I think you
could probably go back a decade before
that to begin to see it the roots must
have been there before that they must
have been because these things don't Dro
down out of a clear blue sky but um the
carrying of lives has
become I hesitate to use the word but I
will indemic in uh some parts of our
society and it is not limited to those
who belong to
gangs but if those who belong to gangs
are carrying knives and creating a
violent situation for others to be
living in then the risk of the others
carrying kn lives in response is
enormously increased and when you saw
these people who were carrying knives
and were accused of murder did they were
there commonalities between them did
they have did they share certain
characteristics we've already mentioned
the age thing 25 and under what type of
people were they
um well um I don't want to sound like a
bleeding heart um but I guess people
that we as a society
didn't sort out look after care enough
about recognize their problems
um there are bad people there's no
there's no two ways about it there are
there are wicked
people but if you ask me how many times
I've seen someone who in my judgment was
truly Wicked Wicked not what they did
was wicked but that they themselves was
were Wicked in the dock I could count
them over nearly half a century on the
fingers of of my
hands if you ask me how many people have
done really wicked things the answer is
I've seen
thousands so the question that maybe we
should be asking ourselves is
why people who are not essentially bad
do bad things and why they're doing it
at the age of 16 17
19 21 and they certainly based on your
experience uh they were not doing it as
much 30 40 50 60 years ago um so what do
you think it is that's causing uh this
increase um
we have
become this may be entirely wrong but my
sense is we've become very short-termist
at least we've allowed our children to
grow up with a sense of being very
short-termist now if I put that in the
starkest terms
um you don't see many gang members in
their 40s 50s 60s and 70s and you laugh
because it is self-evident that you
don't but what that means is when
youngsters devote themselves to that way
of life they're not looking into a
future they're not looking into a
long-term future um a lot of them die a
lot of them are seriously harmed a lot
of them um die from injur inuries a lot
of them die from other things associated
with the lifestyle particularly if they
become addicted to drugs um a lot of
them end up with seriously miserable um
lives in their
mid-30s once you're part of a gang it's
very difficult to extricate yourself and
lead a different sort of Life once
you've been to prison and have a
criminal
record put that the other way around
once you've got a criminal record
whether or not you've been to prison
it's extraordinarily difficult to work
your way back into society again and so
um we've got a whole bunch of youngsters
who are
not as school kids
saying where am I going with my life how
am I going to um have a family have a
career
they're doing something quite
different and if you see the sorts of
backgrounds and lives that they're
living it's not that
surprising it's interesting you say that
and I'm very keen to explore that uh
because I suppose um you mentioned that
we have failed people as a society which
I'm sure their elements of that that are
true but there are we've had many people
on the show who've talked about the
importance of fathers for for example
and family structure I guess just going
to mention the obvious question is of
the people that you've seen before you
as a judge who've committed a serious
crime of that kind how many of them had
an active and present father in the
family as a percentage well
um of the
youngsters
um nothing like what the average aage um
if you went across the whole population
would be I I couldn't put a number on it
and I couldn't put a percentage on it
but um far fewer than would be the
average I um I want to be very careful
here because I don't want to um make it
sound as if because I'm not focusing on
a particular
um ethnic or religious or any other
sector so I think it would be fairer to
say almost every child that you see in
the dock comes from
a difficult home in some way which is
not to say it isn't a loving home but a
home where either there's an absent
father or there's um
illness or there's abuse either sexual
or violent um or there's a a mom trying
to support a whole load of kids at her
wit's ends and so not able just not able
to do that and be in the house
um a whole variety of different problems
if I tell you
that around 50% over 50% of people not
just youngsters not just those charged
with murder but of all people in prison
are what you might call functionally
illiterate or have a reading age of a a
a primary school child and not a child
at the end of their primary school
education to me that
is it cannot be
coincidence it it means we've got a
whole section of society
that
somehow have
not have
been I don't want to say excluded
because nothing's been done to
positively exclude them unless they have
been excluded from school but we haven't
taken the care to include
them and you see the result now that's
only an example of one thing so to go
back to the question that you're
asking why are um kids carrying knives
what are the problems in their
backgrounds yes an absent parent is h a
profound problem um you
see young kids who are absolutely well
behaved till about the age of
11 12
and then the absence of a male figure in
the family can certainly doesn't always
but can lead a child to start to look
for other links um approval from older
men and they are absolute prey to uh
being drawn into gangs so um it's a
problem I think this is a point doesn't
get spoken about enough I I used to
teach in very a very deprived part of
East London and I saw some of the
children because I was a primary school
teacher at the time I was teaching year
six which is 11 year olds and I knew the
ones that were going to go into that had
were at the risk of gangs because many
of them were
vulnerable and these gangs pray on the
weak and the vulnerable and I don't
think that gets spoken about enough they
target them specifically yeah I me it's
it's true um and the rise in what is
called modern
slavery um and the rise in the number of
children being used on county lines
quite young children who um are Wendy
I'm so sorry to interrupt could you tell
our audience what county lines are
little county lines okay um lines refer
to drugs lines so when you're selling
drugs not when you're selling drugs when
drugs are being sold um phones are used
as a method of communication
advertising um identifying places to
exchange
drugs usually the phone that is used is
called a dirty phone in the sense it
will be unidentifiable in various ways
to the authorities it began in London
but increasingly drugs gangs realized
that they could sell their drugs out of
London out in the counties and so they
would put drugs lines out in the
counties the drugs lines would be um
supported by people who took drugs down
there uh maybe to a safe house may or
may not be the ones who were selling
them but their job would be to take the
drugs down there to bring the money back
to account for the
money um and
increasingly vulnerable children uh by
children I'm using the term in the in
the way we would use it in a courtroom
which is under 18 children and young
people um uh do it and I was going to
say are used I didn't use that
expression I'll say do it
because we might think they're being
used they are in fact being used but in
awful lot of kids don't recognize that
they are being used they think they are
big man they think they are part of the
gang they think they're making choices
well they are making choices but they
are not informed choices and the reason
they're not able to make informed
choices is is because they are
vulnerable and they are targeted because
they're vulnerable and they're groomed
as well aren't they that's the way I see
it I mean everything I'm saying guys
everything I'm saying is only how I see
it you shouldn't think I've got it right
necessarily but this is how it looks to
me well that's why you're here for your
opinion yeah and Wendy so how do we go
from boys mainly boys that I taught who
were 10 11 years old to being in the
dock at the Old Bailey with a murder
charge at the age of 18 19 20 whatever
it 16 16 177 18 yeah 16 17 18 15 I see
them I've seen them at 14
um how how do you go
um it's as easy as pushing a knife into
a body
that I mean it's as easy as that if you
don't carry a knife you can't stab
someone if you carry a knife there
is a real risk that the circumstances
that you find yourself in will lead you
to using it or that the circumstances in
which you find yourself will lead
someone you are with to using
it and if you have got a knife in your
hand the only difficult thing about
killing someone is getting the blade
through the skin once you get through
the skin there's nothing to stop
it hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
man's health by his ability to wrestle
be in London I have since found out this
has very different meaning we've all had
a night that's got out of
hand we will speak no more of this the
secret will be buried with my ancestors
well if you want to stay healthy and not
feel like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients once scoop and you feel like
real man we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great looked great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bear which we all know
is grotesquely weak compared to Greater
Russi B if you're looking for a simpler
and cost effective supplement routine
ag1 is giving you a free oneyear supply
of vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
a1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try ag1 and get five free ag1
travel packs and a free one-ear supply
of vitamin D with your first purches go
to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like
me I was listening to an interview with
you on a podcast I can't remember the
name of the podcast now but you made a
very profound point and you told the
story of a young man who deliberately
ran over another man and
killed him and the family could you tell
that story for our viewers and listeners
because I feel it's actually very
instructive as to the importance of
family and how this man ended up in this
particular
situation well um it has to be said that
was a peculiarly horrible
case the man who drove at the victim
um clearly was found by the jury to have
done it
deliberately but what he couldn't have
planned was trapping him underneath the
car he couldn't have envisaged that
happening he couldn't have known that it
would happen it probably never crossed
his mind that it could
happen but it having happened he then
drove for nearly a mile uh with the man
trapped under his car and by the time he
stopped there wasn't a lot of man under
car left but there was quite a lot of
man up the road
um and so from the family's point of
view it's very hard to think of anything
more painful to come to terms with this
would have been um a slow death because
he could have be heard
screaming uh which which is why people
turn their cars to
follow um it must have been peculiarly
painful and drawn out so if you want an
example of how a family facing the worst
sort of Crisis um deals with it that
would be quite a good case to take it
has to be said the degree of
criminality is
about as serious as you can envisage but
in terms of the way the law looks at it
it would not Merit the same sort of
sentence as if um he'd been shot by the
defendant and you look surprised I will
exp I will explain that in just a moment
the way the way in which the law works
and the way in which sentencing for
murder cases at Works don't let me
forget come back to it I'll explain it
but from the family's point of view
it's I mean a young man and so you've
got um parents you've got siblings I
can't remember whether in that case
there were grandparents but it's quite
likely there were um friends the sort of
thing that
is never going to fade in their minds
and judges have no power to you it's
what I always say you can't can't Undead
a dead body judges can do certain things
they can punish they can try in some
cases to
rehabilitate um they can try and make
sure that things don't happen again but
what they can't do is reverse what's
happened which is bringing us right back
to where we were before which is to say
the courtroom isn't where we should be
looking to stop crime happening the
courtroom can only deal with a wrong
that has happened and you can't undo
what's happened certainly not when it
involves physical hurt or death to stop
it happening you've got to go way back
into schools into family homes into the
problems of society agreed uh completely
and yet we do have court
so I think it raises a fundamental
question uh Wendy because I I know
having met some of the other judges atll
Bailey I was there for for an event you
know there's a core a lot of you seem
very soft and cuddly but there's a core
of Steel to all of you um and I suppose
the question that it raises is what is
the purpose of a courtroom and what is
the purpose of the Criminal Justice
System what is it for
exactly well um
if you ask the man in the street what
it's for um he'd probably be say say
something um
like to punish people who've done
[Music]
wrong I
wonder and this is something I I explore
in my new book um I wonder if in fact
that's not quite the right
analysis I wonder if what we should be
saying
is the purpose of the criminal law is to
lay out a system that means Society can
function safely and
confidently in other words the people
who are being protected by the criminal
law are not individual
sufferers individual
victims they are all of us MH
once you say that things make a lot more
sense it would explain why the
prosecution in a criminal court is
brought not by the victim but by the
crown the people in the name of the
people why we have the crown prosecution
service where we have a barrister who is
um on his feet or a solicitor on his
feet representing the crown that is the
prosecution it would also explain why
the criminal courts are the one set of
Courts where the judge doesn't make the
vital decision the vital decision guilty
or not guilty is made
by the people or those who
represent the people um so if you start
out analyzing it in that way mhm the
whole thing begins to make a lot more
sense you're asking then what the court
can do well um I guess I'm asking
something else actually which is what is
it there to do because you talk about
punishment I'm sure punishment is part
of it and I want to explore with you
whether punishment Works actually right
um but I think there are you mentioned
it's about protecting society and
creating a safer
society that I think is where a lot of
the conversation is interesting because
um I I don't even if punishment doesn't
necessarily work some people might argue
well putting violent people in prison
and keeping them there is making the
rest of us safer yeah I'm not
um I can't remember the exact question
you originally asked me but I'm not
saying that the court is there to do the
things I've just described I'm I'm
saying the law is there that's why we
have the laws yes if you ask what the
court can do um well we say don't we um
that juries are supposed to um acquip
the innocent and convict the
guilty um it's not actually what we ask
them to do if you actually look at what
we ask a jury to do it isn't to equit
the inoc and convict the guilty we ask
them to
um convict those they are sure are
guilty and to acquit everyone else it's
not the same thing and that's something
else i' I'm exploring in in this new
book that I'm writing it's a very
different
thing um if you ask what the judge can
do well the the answer is the judge
can't do what an awful lot lot of
victims or bered want it to
do the judge
can't
administer
Vengeance um what the judge can do is
impose a punishment as laid down by
Parliament that he can do um and what
the court system can do is to identify
those
where guilt has been proved yes I
understand what I'm asking I suppose is
a bigger question less about just the
court itself and I appreciate that as a
retired judge that's your focus but I'm
curious to think about if your job as a
judges to administer punishment on the
basis of laws passed by parliament on
behalf of the people what is the point
of punishment well first of all it isn't
only punishment a judge a a judge at the
Old Bailey will be primary arily
interested in punishment because of the
level of the crime being administered
but if you look at the principles of
sentencing um a judge's first job might
be not to put someone in prison if there
is any other viable option and viable
options will include thing where crimes
are not so serious where there is no
appropriate punishment but take Tak away
someone's Liberty then they'd be looking
at probation they'd be looking at
training they'd be looking at ways of
helping a a defendant it's not a popular
way of looking at things because if a
defendant's been found guilty they have
done wrong but it's in society's
interests that we stop wrong happening
again and very often sending someone to
prison is is a shorefire way of making
sure they continue to offend because you
put them in a situation where they are
uh mixing with and only with wrongdoers
people whose mindsets are of wrongdoing
so a judge's job isn't
necessarily and only to punish a judge
has to have in mind a whole series of
different things including um
rehabilitation trying to in some way
recompense the loser there are an awful
lot of crimes outside crimes of violence
where you
can approach putting things right by the
payment of money you know where there's
been a crime of dishonesty um there are
some not all crimes of dishonesty but
there are some where you can put it
right by making someone pay money back
so so judge has many different tasks in
in in in in finding um the right sensus
but you want to know um if I'm the man
of the street and I believe that the
purpose of the criminal justice system
is to administer punishment and we as a
society do seem to agree with that we
punish people for committing serious
Crimes by putting them in prison what is
the point of that why do we do that well
um a number of different reasons mhm um
first of all um to
ensure
that let me go one step back you don't
put people in prison only to punish you
put people in prison to protect society
as well agree and to the extent that we
keep giving longer and longer
sentences query does that protect
Society well the answer is in the short
term term and in the long term if it's a
very long sentence yes because if the
door is shut and the cell is locked
you're not out on the street committing
crimes um so to that extent you can
protect people from really really
dangerous defendants that you just think
are never going to stop offending you
can lock them up for life in fact
although we rarely do but in some cases
we do you can
um lock them up in the short term but
there will come the moment in almost
every case that the door opens and they
walk
out at the moment by way of punishment
by way of saying you have done something
so wicked that society says you need to
go to prison for X number of years
we are locking people up for longer and
longer let me go back to something we
raised before and then draw it in to
this question that you've asked me we
were talking about the sentences for
murder when I began to do murder trials
at the bar the average sentence for
murder was the sentence there's only one
sentence it's life imprisonment but a
judge's job is then to say
how long a defendant must serve a
prisoner now must serve before he or she
can apply for parle the average time
when I first came to the bar was between
10 and 15 years the average time now is
far closer to 25 years and that is
because of legislation that has been
brought in specific laws so for example
um if you kill someone
with a
gun um the starting point is 30 years
minimum before you can apply for
Paro if you kill someone with a knife or
other weapon taken to the scene in
certain
circumstances almost all
circumstances where knives are used in
public will be covered here the starting
point is 25 years for all others the
starting point is 15 now the starting
point isn't the finishing point it can
go up or it can go down and those are
the guidelines
for adults let it say anyone 18 and over
they are different people under 18 and
lower um but you can see immediately
can't you that somewhere along the line
an awful lot lot of people are going to
walk out of prison primarily men who
have
spent decades perhaps as long as they
had lived out in the
community in prison perhaps
longer in prison they are living in a
male
society in which they are never really
challenged take responsibility for their
day-to-day lives they are given some
help in learning how to manage their
lives but they're never responsible for
really what happens they've almost never
had a normal
relationship with anyone certainly no
woman um not necessarily someone they
really love they've never never lived
with
children
for you know since they were young
really young now I've only got to say
that for you to see that if we think
they are going to walk out and fit
seamlessly back into
society we're living in a Cloud Cuckoo
Land so so the answer is I'm not sure
what we're achieving
um other than to be able to
say this is so serious that we as a
society feel we must Market by these
very long
sentences it's not for me to say whether
we've got that right or we've got got it
wrong but what I can do is to point out
the results of doing it this is why I'm
asking you I appreciate it may feel like
I'm a pitbull with a with a bone here
but I I'm curious to expl explore the
big issue here which is um why we punish
people in this way now uh you are
essentially saying first of all it's a
statement of our opinion as a people
about how serious and Grave and offense
is and also then obviously there's the
protection of the public for the
duration of that prisoner's uh
incarceration however your point is well
taken which is once the person comes out
they're not adjusted to Society at all
even they probably weren't adjusted to
society before but now they are 35 years
old or 40 years old or 50 years or 50
years old and they've lived an entire
life in a very abnormal situation in
which none of the normal and ordinary
and healthy ways of being have been not
only encouraged but even available to
them I understand that which to me
sounds like partly a strong argument for
prison reform if I may say so however
you're nodding ahead there we I it's all
obvious we haven't got our system right
yes can the one word we haven't used um
which is the rationale for sending
people to prison and the one word that
Parliament would use is deterrence yes
we make longer and longer senten because
we say it deters other others
um look
um you can deter um some single mother
who is desperate um to feed her kids
from saying something that isn't true on
a social security form you know you you
can you can deter someone from doing
that but it
is
self-evident that we are not
deterring young people from carrying
knives by imposing longer and longer
sentences if you look at the the law
that brought in 25e starting point for
the carrying of the use of a weapon
that's been carried to the scene for
which um generally speaking substitute
the words young people carrying knives
the law was part of a a thing called the
criminal justice act in
2003 um look at what's happened since
2003 I don't know how many we've
deterred but life cribes gone up and up
and
up um we're not deterring
people and that has something to do with
the um if I may use the word the
demographic that we're aiming at these
are young people maybe not all as young
as 16 17 but current scientific thinking
tells us that people's brains aren't
fully formed they're not making the best
judgments until they're what in their
mid
20s so
um trying to
deter uh kids of 16 who are and I will
use this expression Running With The
Pack um by saying um you know that if
you get if you kill someone and get
caught and get convicted
you are looking at a very very very long
sentence so don't do it dear isn't
working it just isn't and it's not
likely to because of the way that kids
and I'm not saying these kids I'm
saying all youngsters are they don't
think um in that in that way they don't
have uh they don't have
a reverse
gear a lot of them hardly have a break
to
apply the accelerator is out of
control the um fuel on which they're
running is high
octane um excitement and belonging to a
group can be a motivating factor that is
their there in their faces on a
day-to-day
basis and the the the the distant threat
of if this happens and if that happens
and if the third or fourth thing happens
then that punishment will follow
doesn't compute you you're too young to
remember the dcts where they used to say
it does not compute um but it doesn't
for for for these or for some of these
kids
and of course we should have deterent
sentences in certain
circumstances but we should first of all
maybe stop and think what we're trying
to
achieve and what we're trying to achieve
isn't to punish
wrongdoers it's to stop people becoming
wrongdoers it's not to do something with
the people who walk through the door of
the court it's to have a society in
which people are not walking through the
door of the court it's um what we should
be trying to do is do judges out of a
job how do you let's say you've got one
of these kids in front of you and you're
judging the case and they've done
something heinous doesn't have to be a
kid it could be
anyone how do you you detach yourself
emotionally from hearing the heinous
details of a
crime and then being objective enough to
pass a judgment dispassionately which is
what you need to do in order to
administer
Justice
um couple of things firstly we don't
judges don't drop down out of a clear
blue sky um in this country to be a
judge you have to have been a lawyer of
considerable
experience uh before you can apply to
become a judge unlike other countries uh
we don't have judge school don't have a
judge ba um
you come to the bench via a career in
the law most judges not all but most
have been criminal
barristers when I say most judges most
judges dealing with criminal cases have
been criminal
barristers um when you're a criminal
barister you are much more
Hands-On with the deep and dirty stuff
you are in the cell with your client
talking to him every day you are handson
with the victims if you are Prosecuting
you are working with the officers who
have been at the seene
you are looking at the depths of the
evidence some of which is just never
going to be shown to the jury but you
before you get on the
bench you know what's coming and if
you're not able to deal with it you
wouldn't be doing that job I think
that's that that's the first thing
whether we become hardened inured um
whether we're a rotten lot in that sense
I I don't
know the second thing is of of course
you have to detach yourself
but there's a difference between being
sympathetic which is useless in a judge
it's a waste of space it's a waste of
emotional energy and it makes you a
worse judge there's a difference between
being sympathetic and empathetic which
is something I think every judge should
be you need to be able to understand
where people have come
from um and I don't just mean defendants
you need to be able
to understand everyone in your
courtroom a judge of course has to know
the law except you don't have to know
the law you have to know where to look
at the law you don't have to have
everything in your head um you have to
be able to handle it find it and handle
it but what you do have to be to be a
good judge in a jury trial is a
good man manager a good person manager
you need to be able to manage a
courtroom packed with people defendants
Witnesses
jurors
barristers public Gallery stuff you have
to know what's going on in every water
of your courtroom that comes through so
strongly in your book as I was reading
it I can see how carefully you think
about the managing different people and
what this person is about to say and why
they're saying it it's fascinating yeah
and I mean if you can't do that try
certainly at the Old Bailey where we're
dealing with really serious stuff trial
after trial is going to go
wrong you know I I've had cases where
I've certainly had one case where I had
nine defendants in the dock so it must
have been way before Co because we
haven't done that since Co um but nine
defendants in the dock
um eight of whom belonged to one family
and one of whom didn't and um the blame
was being put by eight on the one
and the
one was not Copic
and it was very hard to know what to do
because um he was becoming
unmanageable I can control what happens
in the dock in my courtroom what I can't
do is to control what is happening down
in the cells although I can make sure my
staff down there keep an eye on things
still less can I control what happens in
prison Vans or back in the prison I can
contact the governor and say please make
sure this prisoner is on a different
Wing to the others but what I can't do
is stop the others speaking to friends
of theirs who are on the W other wings I
can't control
that in the end what we did uh really
because everyone wanted well the one was
happy with this happening and because it
was the only way of making the trial
viable was he was in such a state that I
didn't think it was right or safe to
have him brought to court and we we
linked up a video and he remained in
prison in the video suite and day after
day joined
in uh from the video suite and there
were times when he wasn't coping and he
got up and he walked out the same thing
could have happened in the courtroom the
jury could see what was happening
um
it there are ways of managing most
circumstances I mean I've had another
case where
um the victim was a young girl who was
holy innocent completely and utterly
innocent it was a case of mistaken
identity when she was stabbed to death
and the public Gallery was packed with
um not just her family but with her
school friends with local people and
they all arrived on the first day
wearing
t-shirts in blazoned with her face and
her name and one
entirely understands how they felt
but they were sitting right opposite the
jury and when the
defendants barristers said how come they
have a fair trial when the jury is
staring into the image of this dead girl
in blazoned upon t-shirts worn
by Young school friends of hers at local
people who knew and loved her they had a
point too and so one had to
find a way of
balancing the issues there one had to
find a solution and believe me there is
no textbook that gives you the answer to
that and
um you can only do it
by understanding what's going on
and using a bit of imagination and
finding some solution and what was the
solution in that particular case Wendy
um in that particular case I um said to
those and I mean this wouldn't
necessarily have worked but it did um I
said to those in the public gallery that
I entirely understood why they were
doing what they were doing that I
entirely understood they wanted to keep
the image of uh this girl close to their
hearts that they might reflect upon the
nature of the trial and the purpose of
the trial and the fact that she would be
closer to their hearts if they turn
their t-shirts inside out and they all
went off and turned their t-shirts
Inside Out wow Wendy what do you I mean
this is do you ever feel that I I think
the the problem is worse in America than
it is over here but if you have money
and access to money
you stand a much better
chance of getting off because you have
access to better lawyers better barters
and have you ever seen that mismatch in
court where you have an inexperienced
Barrister against a high level QC and
you're thinking to
yourself there's two different questions
there um the first is whether um you can
buy um better
representation
the answer is that almost every
defendant um in a murder trial almost
all of them will be legally aided I I
even if they're making some sort of
contribution because of legal aid rules
um almost all of them will be um on
legal
aid they'll almost all of them will be
in
custody um so
mostly that isn't a question that
arises
however we have a thing called the cab
rank rule where for barristers top to
bottom beginning to end if you are
instructed by a a solicitor or even
directly by someone in a particular case
if your experience and knowledge is such
that you are a suitable person to handle
the case you should do it it's like cabs
pulling up you're not entitled to say I
won't take that case and
so by and large
um very very top barristers dealing with
murders are on legal
aid the separate
question
is do you get a mismatch and the answer
is yes you can now you can get a
mismatch whether someone's paying
privately or not you can get a mismatch
even if both Lots if one's on legal aid
and one's been paid by the crown
prosecution service and there has in the
past been um complaints that um better
people defended sometimes than were
employed by
the CPS that isn't my experience and
some of the absolute top uh people who
prosecute
murders are are engaged by the crown
prosecution service so I think that it
is at a lower level that of crime that
you tend to get a
mismatch uh that can happen my
experience is if you get a
really dim I say that with hesitation
and with the greatest of respect to all
my learned colleagues dim person on one
side and the Really clever person on the
other side it's the dim person who
usually gets the result because the jury
see it the jury can see it and it
worries them they worry if they think
someone isn't getting a fair crack of
the whip one side or the other isn't
getting a fair crack of the whip so I
don't think it necessarily in a criminal
case makes a huge difference but um
there is no doubt that if you've got a
lot of money um particularly in fraud
cases um where sometimes a lot of money
is swilling around you can go to top
people and I wouldn't say it never
happens but I would say I do not think
that it is a big problem in serious
violent crime which is is the end of the
market that I've been dealing in that's
very interesting Wendy we've got about
five minutes before we go to questions
from our audience on locals but um I was
curious uh we've been obviously talking
about many of problems with the system
that we have in this
country would would you say that the
British criminal justice system is the
Envy of the
world um I think it is um which is not
to say we've got everything right of
course um it's degrees of getting it
wrong isn't
it we have a criminal justice system in
which although people have
expressed disqui and the strongest
disqui they feel able to do that and to
point out what's gone wrong and to
demand that it's put
right deep down
people um
not all people but most people believe
that we can achieve something
approaching
Justice
um if they didn't the system wouldn't
work you know if defendants didn't
believe that they were going to get
Justice in a courtroom they could put a
stop to our system working like that um
if they didn't cooperate if they didn't
instruct their solicitors and barristers
if they refused to get into a van to
come to court if they refuse to come up
to court if they refuse to listen to the
evidence or refuse to give evidence if
they refuse to cooperate in the trial
procedure we couldn't make the trial
procedure
work um the same with jurors if people
weren't willing to give up their time
and their energy to leave behind their
own problems to sort out society's
problems we couldn't make the jury
system work so um there is an inherent
belief there is one area we do have a
problem with and that is certain
Witnesses in certain circumstances being
frightened to come to court and not
wanting to
cooperate and um judges have powers to
make it easier judges have powers to
Grant
anonymity they have powers to um allow a
witness to give evidence from outside
the courtroom in certain
circumstances they have powers to allow
the evidence to be
pre-recorded both in Chief giving the
account to the crown and now in
cross-examination as well so there are
all sorts of things the judge can do
um so there are many many different
problems
but I think it is true that people still
believe that the system we've got with
all its
faults it's slow it's
expensive um but with all its fults the
actual system in the courtroom I'm not
saying what happens before or what
happens after but the system in the
courtroom of identifying guilt and
passing a
sentence I hope is still the Envy of the
world very interesting so you you
retired last year um which gives you
some leeway to say uh you know I did
this for many many years if I were in
charge here is one or two tweaks I might
make or changes I might make what would
they
be
um one of the things I would
do and it echoes what I've been saying
before is I'd go right back to the
schools not this time to pick up the
youngsters who might be committing
crimes but because I don't think that we
as a
nation understand our
system and that is not the fault of the
nation it's the fault of people like me
of the barristers of the judges of the
system the system's there for people and
we ask people to trust it and we ask
them to participate in it as jurors as
Witnesses um and so
forth they are in entitled to understand
it that's why I've written the book that
that's what it's about I I spent years
as in addition to the day job as what is
called a diversity and community
relations judge and I know how puzzled
people are by the system i' go right
back into the schools and make teaching
the system part of the curriculum part
of Civic responsib
and I would teach children how to sit
down in groups of 10 or 12 and talk
through an argument teach them how to
listen to each
other how to express their
views how to be willing to adjust their
views without losing fa if they find
they are persuaded by another argument
that is what we ask jurors to do and
they come to it
blind they come to it for many of them
never having done it before it it's a
credit to the human nature that they do
so well but we could make it a lot
easier for
them Wendy it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the show the final question is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
I I would like to pick up something
which we have spoken about but we've
only spoken about it in terms um
of
prisoners and that is problems with
literacy there are problems with
numeracy as well but problems with
literacy in our society are
real um 50% % more than 50% of those in
prison
are functionally illiterate or at least
have the literacy level of a primary
school child and a young Primary School
child no one in our society can function
without some basic literac literacy
skills and if you think about what you
are deprived of um
I and I'm not just talking about
prisoners right across the country it's
not just that people have difficulty
with dealing with everyday things what
if you can't read what's written on a
label when you're buying something in
the supermarket what if you can't read
the letter that comes through the door
that says your electricity is about to
be cut off unless you do X Y anded what
if you can't um use a computer what if
you can't fill in a job
application what if you can't do what
your children are doing and learning to
do at school can't read to them can't
work with them what if you can't remove
yourself from what is sometimes a pretty
Grim Reality by reading a story that
takes you somewhere else you know guys
if you or I were locked up in a Cell the
first thing we do is ask for a pile of
books what if you can't get your head
out of that cell because you can't
read what if you can't talk to people
about the things that you are reading
can't attain a better job or any job
because you can't read so the one thing
I would tackle because I think it hits
at so many different levels is um
the different things that people lose by
not being able to read and I've actually
um been doing a bit of work now I'm
retired with a a thing called the
sheriff's and Recorders Fund in which we
have set up a
specific charitable arm to deal with
young people in prison who are having
difficulty with literacy skills that's
so interesting you say that I was just
watching the other day an interview with
uh a drug dealer in America in La I
think uh I think his nickname was
Freeway Ricky he went to prison for
selling millions and millions worth of
drugs iliterate and he learned to read
in prison uh he read a whole bunch of
books and came out and became a very
successful businessman yeah um because
he was
smart and when he could read he could
read the the things that would make him
smarter and better and then you didn't
need to sell drugs to make lots of money
that that that is interesting um so um
that's one of the things that that's um
the work's being done at a a prison for
young people on the east side of London
people um between the ages of 15 and 25
16 and 25 no I've got that wrong 18 and
25 but it's one of those things that I
think um people like me really ought to
be trying to help with that and a
million other things fantastic well
Wendy we're going to go to a bunch of
questions from our supporters that only
they will get to see the answers to on
locals but unlawful killings I like I
said I inhaled it in an evening it's
that good and thank you so much for
coming in and talking to us as well when
does really appreciate it my pleasure
thank you so much heading over to locals
guys have you had any case that made you
lose faith in
humanity
[Music]